I'm Anthony and it's time for another Screening
Room.
We watch a movie, review it, and talk about
it in the comments.
All the movies we watch are available on Netflix
in the US- if you wanna watch along with us
and help support DNews, just head to netflix.com/dnews
and sign up for a free trial membership.
Today we're taking a look at Cutie and the
Boxer, which is one of this year's Oscar Nominees
for Best Documentary.
It takes a look at the lives of artists Ushio
and Noriko Shinohara, who met in the 1960s,
when Noriko moved from Japan to New York to
become an art student and Ushio was big in
the underground art scene.
Ushio was 42 and Noriko was 19.
The movie begins on Ushio's 80th birthday-
and by jumping back and forth through their
lives, Cutie and the Boxer tells an amazing
story about marriage, family, and the art
world.
Ushio's art has always been regarded as influential
and flashbacks show him with people like Andy
Warhol, but he and Noriko live pretty much
in poverty- and while he doesn't seem to care
and barely thinks about paying the electric
bill, Noriko is tired of living their lives
with too little.
Her own work has also been pushed aside, because
Ushio considers his work important and he's
tried their whole life to push her into the
role of loving wife and assistant- even when
her own art is starting to take off and become
more popular than his.
One of my favorite things about the movie
is just how well it captures the depth of
this decades old relationship.
They love each other, but they have no filter-
they don't censor themselves whether it comes
to talking about each other's work or what
they feel like their lives would've been like
if the other hadn't messed it up- but they
also show how clearly they need each other
and care about one another.
It's also a great depiction of what it means
to really love and become obsessed with your
work and how creativity has to be its own
reward, because no other reward might be coming.
It's an absolutely beautiful story, and if
you're interested in personal stories or the
creative process, I think you'll really love
it.
Okay, your turn- the movie's available now
on Netflix in the US, not sure about other
countries.
If you want to check it out and help the show,
sign up for a free netflix trial at netflix.com/dnews
and then let me know what you thought of Cutie
and the Boxer in the comments- and be sure
to subscribe for more DNews.